building the dna early on not to get
panic
and to do the right thing at the right
time and be as efficient as you can
that's that's my passion and to help
those companies
uh grow early on to the right you know
to the
the centric to the customer-centric
focus rather than
be disappeared all over the place
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
let's meet one of israel's top investors
today we are joined with noga cop
managing partner at i3 equity partners
miss nogakop is bringing over 20 years
of hands-on experience in the executive
positions in the high-tech industry
as well as one of the most prominent
women investors in the israeli ecosystem
ms kopp is a managing partner of i3
equity partners
an early stage deep tech focused fund
invested by the largest corporations
such as microsoft qualcomm ge tata and
others
noga cap thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders i3 equity
partners how are you today
i'm fine i'm great thank you for having
me today uh thank you for joining me the
background behind you is beautiful i i
know that it's not a virtual background
but it really
could be for a lot of people so i think
it's it's a
great place to be especially you know
over the past
year or so uh noga um you are the
managing partner at i3 equity partners
for almost five years now and before we
get to talking about
venture capital and i3 equity partners
in tel aviv and what you're doing there
i want to know you a little bit better
and how
what what led you to you know to
create this fun and be the managing
partner five years ago what happened
until then
sort of the big milestones in your
journey that told you i want to be
a full-time investor so
my journey started as a young system
engineer many many years back
maybe the highlight of that was a
company called mint
under the supervision if you like of the
gm
of aviv and de vrat and many
years back
and i was actually what what we call in
april the footspa
type of person coming up as a young
engineer and suggesting a different way
of
looking at the company and i penetrated
completely a new uh
if you like market and i think that
my inspiration is entrepreneurship
i'm not an entrepreneur although i'm
very much
into it but i was at the time i didn't
know to call it that way
but i was coming with a unbelievable
idea that changed completely the whole
company
and on their behalf i moved to europe it
was european-centric
type of company not the american story
but the european
and i moved to switzerland it was
related to the banking industry
and that's where i moved on to executive
positions opened the
as i said the first office in europe and
then had finally eventually
after many many years i had five offices
tens of
financial institution customers very
very successful
just about going public there was this
an amazing
nice company new stock exchange company
by the name of sangat
coming to us and offer us an offer that
we couldn't refuse
i was of course part of them managing
i would say key people in the company
and we decided to move on
thereafter i moved to the other side of
the fence
to the venture business going back to
israel and joined walden
vc an american west coast based
venture capital to their israeli office
their third fund and started my new
venture
as a venture capitalist
wow and so going back a little bit
to the first big venture that you're
part of
you know when i hear you in that quick
one minute tell a brief about
how you went from you know working the
company to being a key player to them
being a part of the
of the strategy you know it's it seems
like it's overnight but but it can't be
overnight right tell me
share with me a little bit you know what
what that journey was like for you and
and
now that you're reflecting back on it
what can a young entrepreneur like me
learn from from the time that you spend
in that company
and i think that you need right
environment
and the right people around you in order
to make it happen i mean very people are
shy away from coming up to their
management and say listen what we do is
great but we can do something
even greater and that's what happened in
my case i
actually joined a local expo during the
weekend that i was kind of
bored uh while you know installing a new
solution a new platform to one of our
customers
and i came across um a new
if you like um um concept
of the swiss national bank that wanted
to change completely the way that
they'll interact
with the local 650 banks in switzerland
and i came to conclusion that what we
have in on hand
is one to one of what they need except
that we don't understand anything in
finance
wow international institutions and i
came back to our headquarters and told
them listen
what what these guys are doing this is a
regulation
this is going to conquer the world all
the financial institutions in the world
probably will follow
let's go and do that and they told me
listen great idea but do it by yourself
uh try to uh be part of the whole
revolution over there
and i and and kyle blanche you have a
ticket to go back and forth as many
times as you need
and i joined the swiss national bank
task force
in order to embrace and
explain the way that we would do that
and the rfp towards all the banks in
switzerland were
was based 70 percent of it on the
understanding and the know-how that we
brought from home
wow so and that's something that we
needed to have someone
listening to me and say you know what
we'll give you the chance but leave
the r d and the marketing and everything
as is
let's let's see if it works and as soon
as the
the whole thing is starting to roll uh
you know swiss leg swiss
they asked all the banks to go into the
new clan yeah
had a specific date of cut-off to change
their way of working
and moving us with the system uh
out and selling it like like razor
almost like a swiss clock they're just
amazing
and but it sounds like they know that a
critical piece here
which doesn't happen overnight and it's
not a just a request it's sort of that
trust
that you build with the people that
you're working with right it's not
you know it's not trivial that you're
coming and saying listen i have this new
idea i want to
i want to try it out and they say and
they say great because because it does
hurt the corporation in some way it's a
risk
they're losing you on whatever you're
working on currently
and so it requires a lot of trust for
them to be able to
to give you that responsibility with
that request right
absolutely absolutely so there were many
a lot of discussions around it and
obviously as soon as they gave me the
permission to
to try and have it and just they took me
off
my main job and just started to work on
this specific project
and that was that by itself took a
couple of uh i would say weeks two
months
and then later on the whole process was
something like one and a half years
and then we took everything on board
and just developed from scratch what was
required and
i was the first to implement it in the
local banking industry and then
thereafter it was clear that this is
really the new direction of the company
the company changed their name
and the old product became like the new
product today
to the financial institutions and uh
it was really a great uh a great success
so that's what they call
entrepreneurship but you
really need to listen to people and
that's true also for my companies at i3
i would like the entrepreneurs and the
ceos and founders
to recruit uh you know the top-notch
people around them
some of them maybe are better even than
the founders themselves at least in
subject they cover
and let them come and to you and be sure
that you are listening to them
in order really to take the right
directions whenever is required
don't take it off and just say you know
what if this is not the direction we are
going uh
here uh just uh listen to great ideas
that come up
with people in this video so much and
tell me a little bit
about i3 equity partners this is not the
first fund that you're involved with
you're the managing director of i
believe brm and
and wall and then you were also with
walden so so you've done
tech investments before you've been in
the tech ecosystem for a long time
why i3 equity partners what what is it
so first of all this is the first fund
for me and my partner ron wagner
that we established ourselves so that's
that's by itself a great opportunity
startup
it's a startup completely a startup and
three things i would say characterize
what we do first of all we are
devoted to super early stage that means
we are really first money in the company
we take the biggest risk um
of course we are choosing significant
market opportunities and absolutely
great
entrepreneurs but we would like to be
there first where things are still not
absolutely
clear and there is a lot of work in the
first at least 18 to 24 months
together with the entrepreneur to build
the company in the right way so that's
the first criteria the second one is
deep tech
we are looking at science and technology
based foundations
and those that are coming from the
academia and i would say 80
of our ceos founders
uh either phds from the universities
here in israel
or coming from the technology units in
the army so
that speaks by itself and and they're
really focusing on on
deep technology which really disrupt
different markets
so market wise it can be if you see our
portfolio you'll see that it's
completely diversified can be urban
uh tech it could be mobility security
you name it critical infrastructure
and so forth uh and the third thing that
we're really strong at
is definitely our connection to
multinational corporates both siran and
i are super experienced
in our past life and we are bringing a
lot of value
with these connections to multinational
corporates in our first
fund actually those are our lps
including
organizations such as microsoft qualcomm
ge
tata themselves and so forth and
in our new fund we hope to include also
the traditional
lps such as you know the pension plans
the
family offices and so forth wow and so
that's what is characterizing us now
when you
when you take on the challenge of being
super early and you're you're
i can feel the excitement that you're
sharing here that you you get excited by
the lack of
you know stability right by by how much
you know you can actually be influential
and get involved
you meet let's say okay you meet a
fantastic team and you invest and you're
part of it
then the next day comes how do you even
know
as an investor because i'm sure there's
both a fine balance of not to interrupt
rather not to overbear
but at the same time how do you how how
do you go about thinking through
where should i inject myself and where
should i put you know my
emphasis with this company
so first of all obviously we select and
cherry picking
the cases that we would like to bake
obviously and and you need some
chemistry between you and
founders and as soon as you find that
these people
i really appreciate what you can give
them and they're willing to work with
you
that's the first step and what happens
is
that people are willing to work together
with us
and if we have a weekly meeting which
they always attend that speaks by itself
but in many of the cases we have a call
once a day at least in the first year
or maybe even the first 18 months and
sometimes even couple of times during
the day
and those those scores are coming from
them to us rather than the opposite
so we are not imposing ourselves on them
but we are helping them
early on to do as little mistakes as
possible and to have the short
and the shortcuts in such a way that we
all know that
young startups will go through pivots
and changes
and all of a sudden market validation
that shows that they are not exactly in
the right
product market fit and so forth so
building the dna
early on not to get panic and to do the
right thing at the right time
and be as efficient as you can that's
that's my
passion and to help those companies uh
grow
early on to the right you know to the
the centric to the customer-centric
focus rather than be disappeared all
over the
place that's the idea and so taking on
founders that early being
what i mean what sounds like the first
institutional money
which comes with a lot of
responsibilities being at first
institutional money
how where do you go about you know
thinking through cherry-picking those
companies there must be a hierarchy of
priorities that you say
these are red flags that i cannot you
know that i can
that i don't think i can work with these
are things that are plus and minuses
if you have to picture you know what are
the really top things top of mind for
you
what would they be so and
in terms of you know it's all about
people especially at the
very early stages so one of the things
that we do heavily as we spoke
before that it was like due diligence on
the personality and the person then
being
completely transparent being able to
share also the difficulties
being able to uh to let you know
what's what's up when things are not
necessarily going in the right direction
so that's one thing in general i would
say that we are following the
esg guideline and that's super important
for us the environmental social
and governance guidelines and that's
that's part of what we
we would like to see in the company uh
obviously in terms of the
the asset itself we would like to say
that we are talking on disruption
an existing market and it's not the
type of me too company but something
that is going to be completely unique
obviously with such early stages there
is a chance it will be zero but at the
same time if it's successful it can be
huge
and we would like to take the risk i
mean as we all know we see sometimes a
risk of earth we are risk takers
absolutely with the first money in the
company we know that
our lps know that but we assure them
that we are able at least at these early
stages to bring these companies
from where they are which is precede
usually to the seed and to the a rounds
100 of times of the cases also in my
background
previously to i3 uh i can assure you
that
all of my companies went all along the
processes
up to the later stages of their life
making sure that they know what they do
they have the right kpis
in front of them and they follow them
very strictly
i i don't know if i can think of a
better statistic than
that than what you just mentioned but
and that that's amazing one of the
things that i'm picking up here now guys
that it sounds to me like you're
you you practice being a founder over
and over again
you know you're talking about
intrapreneurship back from your original
company and you're talking about you
know joining early and the excitement of
joining early and the personality and
dealing with those problems what what
part of this
so it's allowed now that we agree that
you're a serial entrepreneur because
every
every week or month you start a new
company basically what
what part of the company building phase
gets you most excited
so um it starts with really the very
early
uh discussions after the post investment
with the entrepreneurs themselves laying
out the
business plan and now talk seriously
about the business plan after the
investment is done because we all know
the business plan is mainly to make sure
that investors are running after you but
then we have reality
and we have to take it and break it
really
into the details and form the financial
part which is the budget and see how we
want to manage it
to the hiring of people uh and
to the the products product is super
important many
of the companies are they kind of
disregard the product at the very early
stages
and leave the function that is called
product or vp product
to a later stage and and take it to
themselves
and usually entrepreneurs that we are
working with are all technical
backgrounds strong
technical background but not necessarily
the the product part
and we would like to see them early on
uh bringing on board
or having their minds into the product
very early on product market fit is the
thing that will make or break a company
at very early stages
and that's the thing we are working very
very closely with these companies
later on of course networking hiring
getting to the customers
as early as possible and so forth noga
i want to thank you so much for coming
here this was so enjoyable
and uh and and i i learned so much and
i i you know i got excited listening to
your excitement which
to me this is the gift that i get from
from doing this show i have three
questions not about venture capital not
about
uh i3 equity partners that's the
question is about noga
are you ready sure all right we'll start
with your favorite subject from middle
school or high school
oh uh you wouldn't believe it biology
and i was supposed to be a doctor a vet
actually biology i was accepted to a
vet studies outside of israel because at
the time there was no vet studies in
israel
but unfortunately i was offered
an offer that i couldn't refuse to work
in london
for a very interesting company and i
took it off but later on i
came back to israel with computer
science and other things but biology was
my
favorite subject wonderful and who would
serve as a
role model or somebody that inspires you
on some capacity
actually i beg the jal waldman at
melanox
i was actually the first israeli
investor
that backed him up and many many years
back it was nearly one of my first
investments when i was
wow and for me is a role model i had the
honor to sit in the board
for the first few years and that was an
amazing and i would say journey together
with him
and especially his management skills and
his spirit
unbelievable and we see the result i
always say that this is my whole model
even before
melanox became what what we know amazing
and what are three words that you would
use to describe yourself
probably we need to ask other people
about me but i think transparency
uh trust and then
capability to convince people i love it
thank you very very much it was great
thank you so much really great
thank you